welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the x-men are officially
crossing over to the mcu with the
trailer for doctor strange and
multiverse of madness confirming patrick
stewart charles xavier is here we should
tell him the truth
and you should tell us which of your
friends are coming too chuck but based
on what this movie seems to be doing
with patrick stewart i have a pretty
good idea which of the other x-men might
return in multiverse madness and in the
mcu beyond now looking back at fox's
x-men franchise the whole thing was
really made up of four to five eras that
all interconnected in weird ways through
random cameos and time travel riddled
with continuity illogic but i love them
all so much like four or five equally
weird and unpredictable step dads each
trying to raise me and impart different
lessons and all of which stuck and left
me with this broken galaxy brain you're
welcome let's go back to the beginning
you have the original era of the first
x-men film in 2000 which actually gave
marvel studios head kevin feige his
start as an associate producer followed
by x2 x-men united in 2003 then x-men
the last stand in 2006. the lineup in
this era was patrick stewart professor x
hugh jackman wolverine ian mckellen
magneto halle berry storm james marsden
cyclops rebecca romain mystique anna
paquin rogue and a whole bunch of other
great actors like brian cox logan roy
and colonel stryker mutants want equal
protection
you're a [ __ ] times were good but then
the franchise split into the wolverine
films that was x-men origins wolverine
in 2009 the wolverine in 2013 and logan
in 2017 those second two directed by
james mangold and really really good
solo films now spoiler warning for logan
but that movie did kill off wolverine
and charles xavier but while leaving the
door open for x23 but around the same
time the x-men films rebooted as a
prequel series x-men first class in 2011
set in the 1960s days of future past in
2014 set in the 1970s x-men apocalypse
in 2016 which is set in the 80s and dark
phoenix in 2019 which was set in the 90s
this new lineup of all these characters
when they were younger includes james
mcavoy charles xavier michael fassfender
magneto jennifer lawrence mystique
nicholas holt beast evan peters
quicksilver ty sheridan cyclops sophie
turner jean grey and again a whole bunch
of other great actors r.i.p darwin but
one of the great things about these
movies is that throughout all of them
hugh jackman's still cameoed as
wolverine doing a pretty good logan roy
impressions sometimes go [ __ ] yourself
but the movie days of future past
brilliantly brought back both the
original cast and the prequel cast to
try to reconcile both timelines in one
shared history producing a pretty great
movie now meanwhile another era was the
deadpool movies ryan reynolds fixed his
character in 2016 after his poorly
received appearance as wade wilson x-men
origins
and then after huge success with that
movie returned in 2018 with deadpool 2
alongside deadpool in these series was
stefan kapichik who voiced colossus josh
brolin as cable brianna hildebrand as
negasonic teenage warhead and zaizi
beats his domino but really these two
movies are set in their own satirical
side universe however deadpool 2 did see
a quick cameo by the prequel era x-men
in the x-mansion and then lastly there
is the unfortunate new mutants one final
attempt to reboot the x-men again as a
psychological horror film a movie that
was repeatedly delayed by the studio
when disney bought fox and kova delayed
everything now i will say all 13 of
these films are definitely worth
watching at least once but the key
movies when it comes to what might be
crossed over into the mcu right now are
the first two x-men film x-men and x2
because really those are the two kevin
feige has the most connection to days of
future past because it established
quicksilver and showcased both major
eras the deadpool movies of course and
perhaps logan just because it was the
end of the two biggest names of this
franchise nothing against any of the
other movies there's just only so much
nostalgia bandwidth in fans minds at any
given moment but the return of patrick
stewart as charles like xavier is a
major sign because stuart alongside hugh
jackman was the face of the x-men
franchise a reassuring symbol of
authority whenever a storyline just got
too far away from home base this was the
guy who'd let you know yes it's okay you
are watching an x-men film just like we
are now in multiverse of madness because
i think this will be the mcu's first
x-men film now the logan film killed off
charles xavier and implied he killed the
x-men as well with one of his psychic
seizures men were noting a similarity to
the westchester incident over a year ago
that left over 600 injured and took the
lives of seven mutants including several
of the
i remembered what happened in
westchester this is not the first time
i've heard people therefore the charles
xavier multiverse of madness must be a
different one from another timeline in
which his universe discovers multiversal
technology allowing him to join the
ranks of this ultron century-powered
illuminati panel the closest we saw to
that in live action was the
post-apocalyptic future of days of
future past set in the year 2023
i mean look outside it's looking pretty
accurate a post-apocalyptic future in
which trask's sentinel technology
perfected mystique's doppelganger
mutation allowing them to hunt down and
eradicate those surviving mutants
professor xavier used a hover chair in
this movie as he did the 90s animated
series he sent wolverine back in time to
stop mystique from becoming government
property their victory causes that
post-apocalyptic future to get erased
and restored in a new timeline sometime
between the first x-men and x2 since
jean grey was still alive not yet
phoenix and kelsey grammer hank mccoy
beast was hanging out now it was
believed by some that that timeline led
to logan but that was never confirmed so
that dates the future past final scene
timeline might actually give us the
charles xavier we have now in multiverse
of madness yes i slice through the
unimportant information right to the
core of these theories i need to use
some quality hardware well thanks to
kamikoto i never have to worry about
that again because kamikoto makes great
japanese steel kitchen knives using
traditional techniques from japan their
knives are used by michelin star
restaurants around the world they only
use premium steel sourced from the mills
in japan and each kamikoto knife is
individually inspected after a 19-step
process which makes them so confident in
their knives that each one comes with a
lifetime guarantee each knife comes in
this beautiful heavy-duty ash wood box
that's helpful for storage and makes
these knives a very snazzy gift for the
home chef in your life they offer a wide
range of japanese steel knives from big
cleavers to steak knives and knife sets
so you'll have the proper blade for any
occasion like all knives this nikiri
knife has a satin finish on the handle
the knives just feel great in your hand
and they're super sharp these bad boys
move into your kitchen and all the other
utensils know that there is a new
sheriff in town and kamikoto has special
offers running for our viewers right now
so head to the link in this video's
description to get a great deal on some
kamikoto knives but also based on the
trailer this movie will bridge live
action with animated universes which
could explain the what-if parallels but
also possibly connect to x-men 97 series
coming to disney plus a series that will
pick up where that 90s animated series
left off if multiverse of madness shows
us live-action versions of strange
supreme of zombie wanda captain carter
this charles xavier could be a
live-action version of the 90s animated
charles xavier so if we consider the
first two x-men films to be the ones
kevin feige has the soft spot for days
of future past to be the last x-men
movie with real narrative weight in the
deadpool movies as the most recent fan
favorites the most likely mutants to
return in this first wave of mutant
cameos in the mcu are the og cast
stewart hugh jackman ian mckellen james
marsden halle berry famke janssen and
paquin as well as the breakout star of
days of future past an actor who's
already been in the mcu evan peters and
of course the deadpool lineup now i'm
not saying this is the only permanent
lineup of the x-men and the future of
the mcu not at all but in this movie if
the goal of multiverse of madness is
patrick stewart flavored nostalgia that
is really the generation we can expect
sam raimi and kevin feige to pull from
to deliver that no way home size to fan
service so in addition to patrick
stewart charles xavier it makes the most
sense to also include hugh jackman
wolverine ian mckellen magneto just to
close the door on that past era but also
to possibly establish one of these
wandas as the daughter to ian mckellen
magneto in a true house of m adaptation
actually i've been working on a house of
m theory with our researcher whitney
she's gonna discuss it all in a video
coming on sunday i'm super excited to
see what she's got so please show her
the love that you've shown me in mt she
is amazing now i also believe multiverse
of madness will give some clarity on
evan peter's role in wanovision maybe
even shown an additional reality where
he is wanda's brother maybe even michael
fassbender as their father as days of
future past and apocalypse began to
explore a little bit now this leaves
deadpool ryan reynolds did claim he's
not in this movie i'm not really
supposed to i guess i'm really not
supposed to say anything about that but
i'm really not in the movie do i hear a
werewolf howling either way deadpool is
getting a third movie that is set in the
mcu which i assume will address the odd
resemblance between cable and thanos but
see deadpool can get away with laughing
through the logic issues there meanwhile
i don't think kevin feige wants to
invite the confusion of oscar isaac
playing egyptian deity host moon knight
in the same universe where he also
played egyptian mutant god apocalypse
and because of that and just really
because of the lower enthusiasm around
the more recent reboot era films like
x-men apocalypse and dark phoenix and
new mutants i would just be a lot more
surprised if characters unique to those
movies cross over into the mcu at least
right away however kevin feige isn't
bound to any logical rules at all the
door remains wide open to cross over any
of these mutants he wants to give a
second chance to regardless of what
movie they were in and establish them as
the main incarnation of that mutant in
the mcu going forward the question
really is does kevin feige his team of
execs including his casting
extraordinaire sarah haley finn really
trusts the casting directors and all
those other movies to have picked the
right cyclops the right storm we'll find
out but at the very least we need a
second showing of eddie gethege as the
absurdly killed off darwin from first
class i can't believe they killed him
off get this man on the call sheet you
can follow me on instagram and twitter
at
a boss follow me rockstar subscribe to
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you